next up I'm going to California I've got
Stacey on the line Stacey how are you
good how are you Chris thank you so much
for taking the call oh yes I'm focused
and not finished how can I help you well
my question is my parents are in a
rent-to-own situation with the contract
under my name
the deadline to put a down payment is
October 1st of this year they don't have
the funds so they're asking me to help
out my me and my fiancee to help out and
put the loan under our names that they
will pay off so my question is should my
fiancee and I take out the loan to help
my parents and then have this as an
asset for us currently I have 30k in
student loans of debt and the same
amount in credit cards my fiance and I
have combined salaries 140,000 okay tell
me how much student loan debt you had I
had 30 30 35 okay and you have how much
in credit card debt about clay 5 okay
and you're okay and what's your income
okay alright because I think you told me
you and your fiance's we can't combine
them yet till you're married okay but
but looking at this so you've got 60
that you make 60,000 you got 30,000 in
student loan debt and 25,000 in credit
card debt
and your parents are wanting you to sign
on for mortgage for them yes it's the
house is the contract has already been
under my name for two years for a
rent-to-own agree marriage and he my dad
has a really bad credit score my mom has
no score at all so I am the kind of only
person and then only child as well so
this is kind of all on me right now
right okay and so who's been paying the
rent Stacey may have been okay paid a
dime in rent no okay
so they've been there for two years
they've been paying it so I mean what I
would do is talk about them getting it
in their name do you know their
financial situation do they have a down
payment on a home no they don't they're
so they're going to get that 60,000 down
payments for the home by himself is
business okay all right well I don't I
don't like the idea of you taking on
this loan I mean financially you're not
in a position to to be honest
financially what you've got
do is get focused on kind of attacking
the debt and cleaning up your own
situation 25,000 and credit card depth
and student loan debt but but I don't
want you signing I mean when you do that
you're essentially guaranteeing this
that means if your parents don't pay
they're gonna be calling you so don't I
don't I don't I don't like this
it puts unnecessary stress all the way
around and if your parents have been in
there you've helped them out right
they've been in it for paying for two
years are they ought to do is go talk to
the landlord sit down look at how it was
paid and show that hey we've been paying
this thing let them get the rent own
situation into their name if they're not
in a position yet they can't buy so they
either need to keep renting from where
they are or looking to find another
place to rent but don't do this to
yourself you'll set yourself up for
failure that's not what you want to do
you're chasing down progress
stay focused Stacy you're not finished